the poles they're melting scientists say
the arctic has been warming up for years
making the temperature
difference between the north pole and
the equator
smaller and smaller the result warmer
oceans
fueling extreme weather events
he's still wearing a woolly hat but it's
no longer really necessary
the ice in spitsbergen is melting
it's a problem that norway's most famous
polar researcher kim
holman has long been warning of
we are losing the arctic as we know it
because
of climate change
this is a forewarning of all the
hardship and problems that will spread
around the planet
[Music]
as the ground melts it gives up its
secrets
here a mammoth skeleton pulled from the
mud in russia's arctic
after ten thousand years in the
permafrost
rising temperatures here are delivering
riches to some researchers
[Music]
a complete skeleton is always a valuable
find
because individual bone fragments
basically don't hold any information
here we know the exact location the
origins of the mammoth
and that it's one specimen
the arctic touches russia canada the u.s
and greenland
but its demise will affect the whole
world
arctic temperatures are rising faster
than in the rest of the world
particularly in the last few years
as the differences in temperature
between the poles and the equator
reduced the jet stream winds which move
weather around the globe
are slowing down the result
extreme weather high and low pressure
systems remain at the same spot for
longer creating floods
and droughts 12 degrees in spitsbergen
might look relaxing
but it's seven degrees warmer than usual
and that
spells disaster
well let's bring in christina schadel
she's a research professor at northern
arizona university she's also the lead
coordinator of the permafrost carbon
network
a group set up to address the issue of
carbon release from
permafrost christina it's good to have
you on the show i want to start with
a recent occurrence tundra fires
in russia tell me what's happening there
so we have seen increased fire activity
in the arctic over the
last years and in particular this summer
and this is because
temperatures are a lot warmer than they
usually are and conditions are really
dry which
can enhance wildfires and
increased fire activity is uh a problem
because
we've so we've always had fires in the
arctic and this is nothing new but right
now the fires are
much larger they are more widespread and
they're much more intense
and if fires are really intense they can
burn through the
top layer and burn through the organic
material
which will then degrade permafrost and
once you have permafrost thawing that
creates a
whole other issue and will release a lot
of carbon emissions to the atmosphere
and that's that's what we're worried
about right
is exactly permafrost
stays frozen for at least two
consecutive years and so
right now there's a condition as long as
it's cold and
conditions are frozen we can keep from a
frost the way it is but with increasing
temperatures that
changes and and what's so what's the
effect that if the release of permafrost
carbon are we talking about accelerating
then global warming
exactly that's what we are doing and
this this
is uh why it also needs to
why everyone needs to care about this
topic and not just the people that
actually live in the arctic
so i personally live in in arizona which
tends to be really hot and dry in the
summer
that's right but uh so you might think
why would i care about arctic
temperatures but
increasing temperatures in the arctic
they cause permafrost to thaw which will
then release more greenhouse gases to
the atmosphere
and more greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere means
we have even more warming and hence it's
really an
acceleration of climate change what do
you say when people say
um if we do have this warming effect
then that means there
are there's more surface area to plant
trees and plants and those
those plants then soak up more carbon
dioxide
so we've solved the problem
that would be a very easy solution which
is unfortunately not quite true and it's
really not as easy as you just described
it
but we have observed that plants do
take up more carbon dioxide and grow
better when it's
warmer but carbon dioxide is not the
warmer temperatures are not the only
thing that plants need to grow they also
need nutrients
they need space to grow etc and then we
are forgetting that
plants grow during the summer but they
don't grow during the winter and
microbes are still active in the winter
even if temperatures are below zero and
so if you're looking at the anal carbon
budget you're actually seeing that
microbial decomposition releases more
greenhouse gases
than plants take them up again during
the growing season
so right now it doesn't really look like
in the long term plants will totally
keep up
i've got about 30 seconds i'm going to
ask you do you do you have the
the technology you need to measure
carbon
release because it seems so abstract to
the layman
we have spot locations where we do
measure greenhouse gases what we need
is more widespread measurements
longer-term measurements and we need
results to be available really quickly
so that we can observe
on an annual basis where hotspots are
all right
christina shadow from northern arizona
university christina we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight you're
doing valuable work
thank you thank you
you